What's Up America you bunch of potheads
yeah that's right Washington DC Alaska
and Oregon all voted for recreational
marijuana use last night of course they
join now Colorado and the state of
Washington uh in that they will all have
recreational weed and this means you're
allowed to just smoke a joint in the
privacy of your own home and nobody's
gonna care and actually the quality of
your wheel go up cuz they're gonna start
getting some dispensaries with the good
stuff you're not gonna have to smoke
schwag anymore that's right and I think
this is a maturing of America because we
really really really it's not a big deal
now is it not a big deal and saying that
people do and then watch cartoons or
take a walk or any of that stuff forget
you know a lot of junk food that's
probably the worst thing that you do on
weed right nobody's smoking weed robbing
a bank I'm pretty sure that's not
happening um but not only is it good
because it's not a big deal but also if
you want to really look at our political
system we should be a unifying factor
Republicans always talk about they want
to get government out of your bedroom
right they want to get government out of
your kitchen table all that stuff well
guess what if the if you'd stop
legislating and stop fighting people on
weed will they let them do something
privately that's not hurting anybody
that's actually helping the local
economy because now they've legalize it
they can get some tax money and let
people smoke some weed and you'd be
standing up for your principles because
you like tax revenue we know right they
want low taxes so sometimes you have to
figure out new ways to get tax revenue
so then you've done that and you've made
government smaller by taking it out of
your bedroom right so that's pretty good
for them of course the democrats the
democrats i like to have a good time
they like to drink it smoke weed so they
should be okay with that no the
democrats generally more progressive so
they don't see a big deal on this and we
can all do better there's so many things
so you got tax money you got making the
government smaller right uh in terms of
crime right now they're literally are
people that are still arrested for
having weed which is not just a selling
weed just for having we we're putting
people in jail we do Pontius stories on
how having too many people in jail it's
actually not so this is one of those
things that could actually be unifying
this could be like gay marriage came
around state to state to state to state
we realize all hell wasn't gonna break
loose right once you got it everything
was okay
you know what you'll have some gays that
are married and you have some weed and
everyone's just going to be okay so
light up there you go